bonjour les hong kong ou merci de
répondre à nos questions présidentielle
et législatives en 2022 référendum
constitutionnel en octobre promet donc
des autorités de transition mais sous la
pression notamment international comment
la population malienne accueille ces
annonces je pense qu'il ya toujours une
crainte est de voir des périodes de
transition interminable mais qu'elle
semble ne pas être le cas au mali parce
que si l'on s'en tient au calendrier
rendu public un auteur de 2020 le
gouvernement de transition s'était
accordé dix huit mois de travail
il a donc jusqu'au mois d'avril de 2020
dur pour rendre sa copie
je pense qu'il aurait été prématuré
d'organiser les élections avant 2020 du
pour une raison fort simple il faut
aujourd'hui interrogé sur la raison
d'être de cette transition
ibrahim boubacar keita avait été déposée
en août 2020 parce qu'ils lui étaient
reprochés l'incapacité à juguler les
violences et djihadistes
intercommunautés puis l'incapacité à
frontenis la crise économique
sans oublier la production rampante et
la transition intervient donc pour
mettre à plat les mécanismes de
gouvernance parce que nos grands
problèmes du mali aujourd'hui c'est le
cas et il faut donc des réformes
institutionnelles
il faut la révision de la constitution
il faut de fonder une nation malienne
modèles avec des collectivités
territoriales forte et autonome il faut
unis seront les enjeux de ce référendum
constitutionnel en octobre le l'enjeu du
référendum est donc de permettre à ce
que tout ce que je viens de dérouler
comme défi intervenants la nation a dit
nous le ferons devrait permettre à ce
que ces chantiers se tiennent
véritablement sadi réformer les
institutions réviser la constitution et
organiser une véritable décentralisation
comme je viens de le souligner c'est
d'abord l'une des revendications
fondamentales du principal mouvement de
au fait des rébellions à savoir le
mouvement national pour la libération de
l'azawad donc écrivent donc coupé les
ponts avec vers le septentrion et est-ce
qu'il ya un favori qui se dégage déjà
pour cette présidentielle
pour le moment on ne peut pas parler de
favori cela dit on ne peut véritablement
parler de favori dans la mesure où tout
est véritablement quadrillé il est bien
vrai c'était la personne et ses
démarches auprès de ce qu'il convient
d'appeler le christ a dit son mouvement
populaire qui appelait la rue et qui a
été devancé par les militaires qui se
sont finalement emparés du pouvoir
mais comme je le disais des
revendications des risk consultant mais
le régime a verrouillé c'est à dire à
quadriller les choses de telle sorte qu
on a même observé une sorte de
démocratie clientèle est parce que tous
ceux qui sont véritablement qui énergie
au sein de ces terribles l'opposition ou
qui pouvaient voir les choses
différemment ils ont été cooptés au sein
du gouvernement de transition
je pense qu on pourrait véritablement
voir assad et les tendances à l'issue du
référendum qui permettra peut-être au
fait d'asseoir et par la suite des
candidats se prononcer le malien vous
venez de parler à l'instant notamment
des menaces jihadistes
on sait que le mali est l'un des cinq
pays en du g5 celle avec le niger la
mauritanie le tchad et le burkina faso
quelles conséquences justement ces
élections peuvent-elles avoir sur la
stabilité de cette région subsaharienne
et sur les forces étrangères présentes
également dans le secteur on sait qu'il
ya l'armée française notamment et sa
force marqué mais je pense qu'en fait il
faut pas toujours vital et un besoin les
élections en elle même ne sont pas
synonymes de paix on l'a vu par exemple
en république centrafricaine ce n'est
pas passé les élections se sont tenues
en décembre dernier que la paix est
forcément intervenus je pense
qu'aujourd'hui il ya une nécessité de
rassurer certains partenaires notamment
la france qui est présente à travers
l'opération barkan mais aussi le g5 sa
réelle qui est présent militairement
depuis 2010 est parce que
mais malienne en elle même elle n'a pas
les moyens de sa politique sa vie pour
assumer les missions régaliennes et mais
aujourd'hui encore il ya un autre acteur
à savoir la russie qui fait aussi
timidement son entrée parce que le mali
ou alors la transition s'est attelé à
une heure pour l'utilité de la bascule à
savoir ce qu'on ne peut obtenir de
l'occident on obtient des laisses des
dons de la russie cela je suppose un
nouveau paradigme et même dans la vision
de cette crise parce que avec les
accusations qui portent sur la france
est depuis un certain temps nos débats
souriante et peut-être mais la
négociation en négociation avec les
mouvements de rébellion mais elle semble
ne pas être le positionnement de la
russie qui a toujours l'estimé qu'on ne
devrait pas négocier avec les criminels
merci les hong kong ou d'avoir répondu à
une question je rappelle que vous êtes
politologue et spécialiste en relations
internationales